[Music]
christian and i are coming to you
not live i almost said live but we're
recording in connecticut we're looking
out the window and it is
snowing those huge flakes you know i
always think of charlie brown christmas
those big flakes that come down when
it's like this oh yeah i wasn't thinking
that but now i am do you get excited
when it snows like i always also get a
little that's a leading question i know
but do you still feel i mean i don't
fear this i love it yeah i know not as
much as when we were kids but when we
were kids obviously like the you know
it's the promise of not having school
and getting to have a snow day and
whenever we would have a snow day we
made a beeline for
the park sturgis park where there was a
hill at the time i thought it was like a
mountain you know it was like the swiss
alps um and we would sled down there
with all the other kids and we usually
got there a little late it was mostly
mud at that point with little remnants
of snow yeah but it was slick it was
like yeah slick mud but then you'd see
kids coming home and we'd walk home with
like uh skid marks we'd have skid marks
all right so fun so fun do you think we
should go do that now
uh we're not far from there um i would
do it you know i've done it as an adult
on that hill
also
because we're the age we are right well
you can't go when other kids are there
exactly yeah
it's a bad look that's true okay so no
sledding for us today but podcasts yeah
we get to do a podcast which is
the our adult version of a fun snow day
we get that fun doing that
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for short i am
your snow loving host
justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is um
i i think you love snow actually more
than i do christian long how can you
possibly say that because i'm i'm always
running off to
l.a warmer i i can't
you know i like the i think that's more
of a cold thing maybe than a snow thing
isn't it don't they go hand in hand no
it's not you leave
you leave because it snows too much
no but that's a a byproduct
maybe then maybe if that's the if that's
the case then i guess you're right you
can't drive you you're like i like the
snow i do too it's supposed to flurry
today yeah and it's not flirting it's
like really you know those big thick
flurries flakes yeah really snowing
it's so beautiful it's beautiful how do
you not like this i love it i i don't
not like this
i'm saying like
i found myself
staring at it earlier and being um
i went into like a trance just
mesmerizing it's mesmerizing it really
is watching the the snow why are you
talking about mesmerizing things well
it's hard to do this now because and
flaky things
wow that's a good i don't know flaky
things no i'm kidding
my back is to the snow now and um
remember you have to talk into the mic i
know i know but i can't look at the snow
and talk you keep doing it though like
now
um you're right why are we flaky well
like me yeah because i'm a flay i'm a
host of this show that uh has a guest on
it today who's not a flake no not like
uh not like me no he's very much not a
flake um what's the opposite of a flake
flake how did that term come about flake
that's just kind of like uh it goes away
the second it falls on something oh yeah
it melts away it's
not solid transitory
temporal it's temporal and it's it's um
it's not concrete it's not grounded
sure
it's not anchored by anything untethered
flakes are just kind of like they fluff
our guest i will say is
for perhaps whatever that opposite of
flake would be yeah i don't know what it
is but i think it would be him uh yes
also we were talking about
our sledding hill sturgis park shout out
can you shout out a park i guess why not
yeah why not it also sounded like you
said our [ __ ] hill our guest was a um
an actor on a very very funny very
well-known show called parks and
recreation yes both of which we did at
sturgis we we recreated at that park um
and our guest today you're referring to
i believe
is
the great
and funny nick offerman
that's my nick offerman um can you
recreate somewhere recreate
then would be recreate maybe not
recreation where does that come from
uh wait a minute
i never thought about this is the word
recreation is it's re-creation are you
trying to recreate something else is
that where
recreation comes from um
create again
recreate reproduce reenact this recreate
but why is that word why does it have
that meaning recreation like
you're doing um
some
recreational activities
what does that have to do with
recreating something shorties
uh recreation latin is re-creary create
again renew
maybe maybe something um some leisurely
activity like some leisurely
recreational activity
is
the reason it's pleasurable is because
you're doing something familiar you're
recreating something that brings you
pleasure
and puts you at ease oh maybe
the term recreation appears to have been
used in english first in the late 14th
century first in the sense of
refreshment or curing of a sick person
and derived from it yeah i like to
[Music]
it is refreshing it is it rejuvenates
the spirit
to be um
but do you say recreate maybe to
recreate i don't know i don't know
shorties
who any who um any who are our you know
our guest actually might be into this
little um our guest might be able to
answer this question yeah yes very
knowledgeable human being he is and he's
got a great um
vernacular he's got a rich
um he he speaks in in many ways like um
we said his name right nicole yeah nick
off from yeah so i thought maybe i said
it in a weird way that wasn't nick off
or nick offerman but he is from a
different time i mean there's something
it's not just old-fashioned it's like
it's re it's it's from another era that
the way he speaks and sometimes he'll
use words well we'll get into it but um
you know him you met him
uh doing
the film taking chances correct yes
where you met him yes but she comes up
again it's so funny that that with our
friend kira o'donnell
kier who by the way is in a new movie
called ambulance the michael bay michael
bay movie so check that out it looks
awesome looks great in it not an ad no
not supportive of our frontier
supportive
um yes supportive of care and um you're
supportive of the show so why not he
listens i hope he's listening now um
so check that out he plays a cop so you
work with nick offerman on that movie
too also a friend of the show emmanuel
shrieky that's right friend of the show
rob cordray great cast it was and nick
was um one of one of that a cast member
of that so yeah that's where i first met
nick and um
just fell in love with him instantly he
was so fun so dry and funny we talked
about that how long did you guys date um
we dated on and off for like uh i would
say about six years it was like more
whenever you were in the same town yeah
and then we'd hang out we knew and we
never actually
touched you know it wasn't consummated
no no but it's
so we we're both quite frustrated by
that i think and then he and then he
revealed that he was married and that
complicated things but um
he i would i would run into him all the
time and just always loved being around
him he's uh he's such a unique um
especially for like how actors circles
you know he's he's got such a unique
energy and um
and and is and it's so thoughtful and
uh
like there's a wisdom that he has he's
like an owl he looks like an owl and he
has like um owl wisdom i think that kind
of if he were to be an animal let's hear
some of that owl wisdom let's do it here
he is
the wise hilarious very kind
nick offerman life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
do we even need to say it's great to see
i mean like you know that i know it's
great to see you and you i can't believe
how cute you still are
i was like out of here kind of the main
reason i wanted to do this was for the
shot and freud of like
man he looks old as [ __ ]
well it's not that's nice to hear he's
it's not the best lighting um
that's so nice to hear nick as to you
you look you look the same no no i won't
be molly coddled on your podcast
mollycoddle who i want to mollycoddle
you also are a man of many skills and
many practical skills
you're an incredible uh wood
worker would artist witness wood
woodworker and uh cocksman or swordsman
yes there's what the audience will be
missing is the just a hint of a smile
that
that
comes onto your face when you say those
things but you are you know many you
have many skills and and i would imagine
that well
i have seven skills
what let's name let's go through them
each connelly i guess
which presages uh my my sword skills
uh what i can do with my rapier
now were you did you perfect the
former skill first and then you felt
like well now i need
i need something to follow it up with in
all truth when i was a teenager and uh a
generous uh older teenager
uh of the female variety took it upon
herself to teach me
uh how to fornicate
me too
she was a cool open-minded person and so
yes she
she said look i don't know if you've
read the news but women have kind of
gotten the short end of the stick
they're one of the groups
that has not yet come out exactly on top
uh no pun intended and and so
if you can uh you're really gonna
score a lot of points if you can like
uh please you know basically
you start be generous from the get-go
and it's i mean by and large that was
wonderful advice because i bet when you
when
traditional
sort of uh cis hetero
uh love making techniques are often
pretty misogynist or like male forward
as as we were told by like john hughes
movies
uh and now
to to be told like oh no actually
if you
uh go into this with generosity and
kindness
uh it's how everyone should be a but b
it's not exactly selfless because you
stand that you then stand a much better
chance
yes there's a reciprocation of potential
yeah getting to have some giggles of
your own i'm curious how much older this
woman how much older this woman was
um
she was i was uh i was a freshman in
high school and she was a senior
the great the
ideal pro age proportion yes i had a a
similar experience but i was um you know
i was a later bloomer i guess than you
so i was a freshman in college
she was a senior in college but it's
nice to it's also such a vulnerable you
know you grow up at least i grew up not
really knowing
um
what to do there's no
i remember health class didn't you know
help and my parents were you know i love
them and bless them but they
they certainly didn't know how to we
were catholic and so it really wasn't
talked about much and so it was it was
so nice to just feel safe with somebody
um
to to to explore that way absolutely i
couldn't agree more i was also raised
catholic very uh wonderful family great
household but just completely like zilch
that like yeah sex does not exist uh
and and i i used to do a bit about this
uh on stage
um
i mean i remember then like in other
experiences before and after this this
generous person who unfortunately turned
out she was cheating on her boyfriend
and so it didn't last you know in and
around there when i you know in in the
realm of like uh exploring
my sexuality with other partners
there was this sensibility and this is
the mid 80s you know the where i had
uh girls that would say things to me you
know i
as a clumsy you know novice like
should i like should i do this or is
this okay or is th is this your butt or
just whatever
and
and the
the overweening sensibility was shh
don't ruin it
right like right communication is bad
during those moments please magically
just like
send me to the moon with your orgasmic
skills with that with no tutelage
whatsoever that's true and so i just
always encourage like i love when i tour
to colleges i say look if you're getting
into these circumstances just talk like
to your
like your friends like do you want to
do this do you want to do that is this
okay
you know yeah yeah because how else are
we ever supposed to know nick that's
such a good point that's so true that
was always considered whenever like
asking a question or a practical
question about
how to please
it was met with i i know exactly what
you mean like don't ruin the moment it
should just be
silent and there should be the
stereotypical sounds you know certainly
no no education hell no yeah there was i
think
i may be getting this slightly wrong but
i feel like on an eddie
murphy album
i feel like he gave some advice uh for
cunnilingus and he said to recite the
alphabet
oh yeah i believe was the idea and raw i
think and so that's you know that's one
of the only
pieces of direction i received so of
course i i tried it with gusto i even
i tried uh the aramaic alphabet right i
switched up a couple different languages
even got into numbers and symbols at one
point
emojis are tough but and the thing is if
it wasn't working because
again every single person is completely
different like you're right right
whatever one lover
enjoys the next one
some like it fast some like it it's true
you know
yeah yeah so just like talk like be
vulnerable and understand you're both
people
trying to figure those things out and
this well said this has been making love
[Music]
justin long
by the way why not why couldn't we have
that podcast
to cis white men
i also suspect you of like me like um i
wanted desperately to become
an actor and like be a i wanted to be a
bad boy i had a lot of i had a leather
jacket run a motorcycle i shaved my head
i wanted to just be you know
you sound like you could be a bad boy
but you also have a great voice for
being a bad boy thank you i i i i and i
have the build like i have i have all
the tools
except then i get into a circumstance
from like okay uh
jennifer just like before we get into
this
i just wanted to make sure you feel good
like uh i want you to know i care about
your feelings and like you what and like
you know you know about consent right
jennifer
yeah but i thought you were i thought
you were a bad boy well i mean i am i i
love david lee roth videos but i also uh
don't want to traumatize you in any way
ah okay you know what i'm just kind of
not in the mood anymore
um
yeah you the few times that i would have
that were yeah a woman would mistakenly
be like no like ravage me i was like
yeah i don't know i don't know about
ravaging yes
yes i don't want to bite you on the
shelf yes i know what you mean i'm
afraid to
really go into
how my relationship to that um
but yeah there there's some dicey
moments where you don't that there's a
very thin line i think between
you know there's somebody's fantasy and
like you said everybody's different some
people have
want to to do certain things and as a
gentleman lover
you have to be very
uh you gotta like spell it out i think i
think so i think and in all walks of
life like if we can communicate more
that
we all exist in social ruts whether
we're in like a business meeting or an
audition or
uh you know in the confessional or
whatever it is there are received
behaviors and so
we all have well make mistakes we're all
clumsy farting humans and so
i always i'm 51 and i'm
pretty successful at a lot of things and
i still constantly have questions about
my clumsy humanity like right should i
am i doing this right is my compartment
correct i don't know like no i know i'm
new at this and so to be able to be like
hey can i just ask a question
you know
more often than not i think is uh is a
great skill to have it is i think you're
right your point is is taking it i i
just think you have to do it in the
right form i mean you certainly can't go
on twitter and say hey everybody is it
okay to say this no totally
but it's true like the the society
everything keeps shifting yeah that's
true discussing birth control with
somebody discussing
sexuality or or gender topics i know i
know at my wood shop i have a gender
non-conforming person named chris
and every time i see her i still she she
says
she doesn't care about her pronouns like
she transitioned from uh
outwardly female to she she's a trans
man but she says you know what i just
i'm gender non-conforming
but i just always say when i see her i
say
i want to make sure i'm still
doing my best yeah to treat everybody
equitably because
because those things change and and
rather than get mad
yeah or curmudgeonly that i have to like
change my
language system it's just a word
yeah i'd rather be like okay cool that
like
there's a there's a new thing we're
doing with pronouns so that everyone
feels uh more justly represented right
[ __ ] right on like
right and that's all it takes
right all it takes is me like is being
like oh i have to
learn learn a new word for this
yeah i think i can i can take a swing at
that
yeah i mean not to one-up you but i also
just worked with a a non-binary person
and um i was talking to the nun their
their
girlfriend
um but she said um the girlfriend said
you know they're totally cool they're
they understand that there's going to be
an adjustment period people are people
in their lives are going to have to like
you know because language was they had
been calling them this thing for a long
time so it's just it's just an
understanding of an adjustment i think
it is and i mean
i'm just i can't help but recognize my
fallibility at every turn where yeah i
like i'm skilled at memorizing
writing and then regurgitating it in an
effective way like i'll go i'll go that
far and say that that's something i can
do even so
i
i'm not gonna just stop then and be like
okay i'm terrific where's my parade
i'm gonna continue as long as i have the
faculties to try and get better at it or
regurgitating
yeah and
and letting
every part of my life evolve
with society we're a bunch of human
beings so we'll never yeah we'll never
be done we'll never be like okay well
that's it everyone is getting a fair
shake yeah
yeah we did we fixed it all right it all
makes sense now
when did you realize you you loved
regurgitating lines nick so much great
theater came from from chicago and you
grew up in juliet um a suburb there was
that were you exposed to it at that
early in age well just because we're
passionate about our locality if you
look online i was born in a hospital in
joliet that's where the hospital was but
joliet is a small city
uh known for its steel production
and my small town uh of manuka illinois
like i'm a third generation
manuka dweller uh
my parents grew up on farms like three
miles to each side of the house i grew
up in oh wow wow the seven people from
manuka that hear this will take umbrage
if the word suburb is uh oh
and my dad is now the mayor of manuka
you're kidding a fun fact oh wow
was he
into um politics when you were growing
up was that a surprise to you well his
dad uh grandpa ray was also the mayor
for a time oh wow and so like the whole
family has an incredible
uh sense of civic service yeah it's a
huge family there's i want to say
there's 39 of us at the moment
and the only ones that don't live within
an eight mile radius
are me and megan mullally who live in
los angeles
everyone i have three siblings they all
live literally within a block of my mom
and dad oh my god that's so cool so how
often do you get there nick do you go
there quite a bit before the pandemic
yeah and
uh once so far during the pandemic and
do they think of you as all those
offerments think of you as an awful
woman think of you as like an outsider
like a holly like that's our hollywood
son it's um it's
a little weird like my immediate family
of three siblings and my mom and dad
have kind of been on the ride with me
like i did a play in philadelphia and
they and mom and dad came and then i did
something in new york and so
it was their first time like coming to
philadelphia or new york
my family is nurse
two school teachers a librarian and a
craft brewer so there was no sense of
like having to stay in an agrarian world
and
you know not wanting to branch i mean
your parents were open-minded in that
sense that they were like i i said to my
high school guidance counselor i want to
be an actor and they were like no that's
not on the list of choices
yeah yeah in fact none of the arts is
available to you
uh what about lawyer they kind of
perform in front of people
they literally said that to me and i
really and i found out that that i could
study theater at the university of
illinois and i've i just luckily met
these theater students and i was like
wait what do you what hang on huh
and they said yeah we
we study acting and i was like then what
and they said that you can get paid to
be in plays in chicago so so i had done
the plays at my little high school and
and and in the catholic church i was an
altar boy and then
they had me start doing the readings of
the gospel
yeah yeah which is called the lecter
and that i think that was this
that was where the spark happened like
doing the plays was one thing
but being alone on the pulpit doing two
gospel readings before the priest got up
to deliver his sermon
you know and i'm like 14. and i i
learned that i could read these like
gospel readings you know from the first
letter of of steve to the philippians
yeah and jesus came to big old lakes
suckaburrass and he and he did spake
unto the peoples
and
and like i immediately developed
this idea like where my cousin and my
two friends i'm totally cracking them up
the whole time that was the beginning of
this sort of stentorian personality yeah
um
a a a stoicism where i was like as long
as i keep a straight face
my cousin is [ __ ]
dying like trying not to laugh and the
whole rest of the congregation is like
that was a great reading yes that's so
interesting and so that's when i was
like uh i
i feel like i can
do something weird with like making
people laugh i'm sure a lot of people
think you are um
have misconceptions about you uh people
who loved you from parks and rec or a
lot of the things you're known for
people must think you're
politically of a certain mind or
you'd you know are a real meat eater you
know these these real masculine
traditionally masculine trappings and
yet you're a sweet softy you love conor
lingus and vegetables and
i do although i am i mean i am guilty of
being a voracious eater of meat okay
but the i also love health yeah
yeah and so
that's like that's a funny thing where
people have literally said to me uh
after shows
they'll come up to me and say uh my wife
really wanted to come meet you as well
but she was scared to meet you because
she's a vegetarian
no [ __ ] as though
i mean it's because of like a couple of
ron swanson jokes yes as though i'm
gonna what yeah
punch her
get the [ __ ] out of my
i wrote about it somewhere where i said
look i love eating meat uh and i'll just
quickly say i mean this is a huge thing
in my life these days i love properly
raised grass-fed meat i'm a huge
proponent of regenerative farming so
when people
say that cheeseburgers are bad or or
cows are responsible for climate change
neither of those is true uh it's
there's a saying uh it's not the cow
it's the how
and so it's not those items it's
industrial agriculture right
can you explain to people i mean you're
from this world uh can you explain to
people the difference
yes the difference is simply uh
the
origins of agriculture
come from people and
small farmers small farmers still
practice this as well as indigenous
tribes
where
by necessity by pre predating the
industrial revolution
they had to whatever they're growing
whether it's plants
or fishing or or
livestock
they have to do it in a way that's
simply sustainable if you if you have
one acre and three cows and a turnip
patch
you're going to
craft your farming in a way that you can
keep doing it
in perpetuity so you can keep feeding
your family that's like a huge part
of your livelihood and that's it's
called agrarianism it's simply
uh living in a way
in in uh in accordance with mother
nature rather than trying to dominate
her as and so industrial agriculture is
when if you have a piece of land that
can hold 10 cows
grazing your your wild flowers and
grasses and you produce dairy products
or beef or both
and but you build a shed and you put in
a thousand cows
that's industrial agriculture you are
you're now raping mother nature
and and you're causing too much waste
for your land you're causing uh
gas pollution and so on and so forth you
suck essential nutrients out of the soil
too right i mean sure monocultures do
that all of the acres across the country
that we've planted in corn and soybeans
and wheat right one of one of the many
uh sort of ills of that practice is
they they've long since destroyed the
life the microorganisms in the topsoil
so for decades they've just been pumping
in chemicals oh my god and so ultimately
some like you know these huge companies
monsanto cargill etc they're making a
profit by doing this
but but the actual
nature
[Music]
the the life of the biosphere is
terrible tragedy and it's i mean and
it's something the thing is
we we're all complicit like it made
sense it was like hey guys we figured
out a way to make way more cheeseburgers
or so that like everybody can have this
breakfast cereal that's what's
interesting the origins of monsanto and
the gmo movement they were all they were
like
you know real utopian minded
hippies they were they were um real
progressives in the 60s they wanted to
feed
bangladesh bangladesh had been overrun
by by um
floods and so they created rice that
could could live in that those wet
conditions and now it's been
corporatized and well yeah like anything
i mean we're humans like i you know
i i try to never lose sight of the fact
that we're complicit like we're using
electricity right now we'd have to be
pretty naive to be like okay
mr mr electricity i'm gonna send you my
check and i assume you're gonna be cool
right with like how you send me like how
you create power
[Music]
our mother as we talk about too often
probably is having trouble sleeping and
so i gave her plus cbd
plus cbd can help if you're having
trouble sleeping there's sleep gummies
that get you the rest that you need so
you can wake up feeling focused and
refreshed and um they're formulated by a
team of medical experts and doctors so
you have to listen to us don't take our
work
plus cbd sleep gummies taste delicious
they really do i gave one to our father
the other day and he um gladly popped in
his mouth and the first thing he said
you want to know what's delicious and he
goes
yeah they're good they're also made with
award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark and lemon balm
this is the naughty one the extra
special one is the reserve collection
it's a specially curated blend of
full-spectrum cannabinoids that
celebrates their very first batch of
plus cbd oil rich and bold the reserve
collection gummies with 25 milligrams of
cbd and here we go you want to tell them
what this one's 2.5 milligrams of thc oh
yeah they elicit feelings or should i
say illicit feelings of calm and relief
when intense support is needed and this
is a life is short exclusive yes which
our father uh enjoyed last night so why
do you sleep better tonight by visiting
pluscbdoil.com and enter promo code long
for 40
off your order
that's code long at plus cbd oil
dot com for 40 off we've become
beholden to a lot of technology so much
so that it's easy to forget about the
hardware we're born with like the ear
which is the same as fingerprints no two
are exactly alike which i didn't know
that's why your earbuds probably cause
you some discomfort or even physical
pain after a while the ultimate ears
fits true wireless custom fit earbuds
from ultimate ears are here to change
that
ultimate ears fits are the world's most
comfortable earbuds they're they're
premium sound the sound is great it's an
all-day comfort thing and it's really
fun to get them fitted it takes about 60
seconds they mold to your ears it gets a
little warm it's a nice warm feeling in
your ears and who doesn't like a nice
warm feeling in the ears
with eight hours of continuous playback
on a single charge and up to 20 hours
with the charging case ultimate ears
fits are perfect for listening to your
favorite shows
maybe a podcast
you can listen all day long so you can
binge any show but let's face it mostly
life is short if you try fits and don't
love them as much as i do no worries
ultimate ears offers a 30-day money-back
guarantee plus you'll get free shipping
free returns and a one-year warranty
just use promo code long at ue.com
fits to get your pair of ue fits that's
ue.com
fits promo code long
hello again
mean i hear these things i'm fascinated
by the problem but i also get so easily
overwhelmed by it i'm sure a lot of
people listening
feel similarly so how do you
approach it in a piecemeal way in a way
that is less daunting what have you done
in your life like what's the
prescription that you've employed i i'll
tell you the
the secret to uh to my entire approach
is i i go on
podcasts
and speak uh
enthusiastically about the subject and
beyond that
my my family are prolific gardeners and
my my neighbor is an amazing gardener
and some like invested in his compost
bin and his his garden but for myself
i i
read a lot of wendell berry and aldo
leopold and robin wall kimmerer and
other agrarian giants
um and so i i talk about this all the
time and i love to visit them and and uh
support farm to table
uh systems
but ultimately when i i say
i get bummed out that i'm like i should
really have a garden and then
and then i take a step back and i look
at my wood shop in los angeles where at
the moment i have four
uh five employees oh you do oh wow that
so that's grown quite a bit i remember
yeah being there one it was just you i
think when i was what it was just me
for uh for i don't know eight or nine
years and then when parks and recreation
started i recognized that my life was
changing that yeah
it was i was in my late 30s
and i said okay if this show goes
my life is going to change like uh
it's going to shift from the
whatever 18 years of adulthood
suddenly my dream's going to come true
where i'm going to get to work as an
actor
all the time yeah which had not happened
for me
so i started hiring people and i've had
as many as six employees but so it's
this it's this bustling uh if you go if
you go to offermanwoodshop.com
for
you know many years now we we make
commission furniture pieces and we also
have like gift items available that's
awesome i didn't know that and so what's
in woodshop.com my shop is my garden
yeah what got you into that was it would
you your family were they adept at that
i mean my family a lot of them are are
farmers and my dad is like
has always been sort of a
skilled carpenter and even an amateur
furniture maker also self-taught
so so he taught me to use tools and like
work with wood yeah and then uh i framed
houses to pay for college oh [ __ ] and
then when i started theater school uh i
wasn't good and uh i couldn't get cast
but i immediately got hired in the scene
shop and was like oh [ __ ] i can get paid
to build the scenery well you're getting
better as an actor yeah while i'm
waiting to to get cast someday when nick
when you say are you being
self-deprecating i mean like did you not
what
what um
what in what way were you not good like
how would you describe your tell you
exactly because i figured it out
eventually okay and it's an ongoing
project but
when i when i started college i
i mean
i'm astonished that that i uh
that
to this day i've been with my wife for
22 years and she's so talented and
sophisticated and i uh am really
ignorant in certain ways
specifically ways of talent and
sophistication well
i mean
so when i got to college i was so
i had lived in such a cultural vacuum
yeah so i'm in theater school with all
these kids that like
from chicago and the suburbs who like
they had heard of mammoth yeah yeah you
know like savvy you know sam shepard
right enthusiast yeah and let me put it
this way
one of my audition pieces to get into
the theater program
for a monologue i performed a scene of
dialogue from a play
that's how
ignorant i was it's like a while waiting
for goffman it's like the guy do you
[ __ ] my wife what are you talking about
what kind of question is that
exactly but you know nick that's also a
really charming thing and it doesn't
necessarily mean i
certainly doesn't mean you're a bad
actor but i imagine that's the kind of
thing where a lot of knowing theater
kids at that age like there were
probably a bunch that got snarky and uh
well here's the thing i i told them
because you also had to do like an
interview it's a nice conservatory at
the university of illinois they take i
think 16 12 or 16
acting students a year oh wow so it's a
small little thing yeah and so i had
this interview and i was like look i
don't know what the [ __ ] like
you know politely but i was like i have
no idea i come from this little town i
love i want to do this like i want to
perform and like delight people and i'm
totally starting from zero
uh so
take that into account what i like
refresh it must have been such a
refreshing thing for them to hear you
know i just know the way kids who are
into theater can be at that age i'm
going to be a star and i've done you
know 12th night at 12 different
locations
well
that may that may well be i mean i do
think
that every you know going through the
program every year i began to notice
that they would they would cast or they
would uh pick
one or two
young men or women that were uh
beefy and athletic
specifically to carry the talented
people on and off stage
uh either in a palinkin or like a sedan
chair so i mean
and that's fine i mean
whatever it took but here's here's the
thing your beef went to good use
i went through uh my went through my
years of school i graduated tied my best
friend uh
as valedictorian of our class like
i did he was your paledictorian that's
right we were pale paledictorians
and then we started a theater company
together a handful of us in chicago
called the defiant theater
and
it was it was uh towards the end of our
first year
our first season of three shows
i finally
it
i literally took five or six years where
it finally just like soaked into
an equilibrium where it clicked that all
i needed to do was be myself
uh-huh yes oh my god
it took me so the whole time to answer
your question of like is that false
modesty no i was
trying yeah way too hard to be something
cooler yes
than this dumb kid from a country town i
remember seeing you clean shaving for
the first time you know sorry
you have to just put up
that [ __ ] don't fly sorry it's coming
your way uh so handsome so like so like
oh i'm surprised because you you play um
these character roles that aren't
necessarily
don't necessarily need a handsome man
but now
come to find out you're hiding a
handsome face
well that's that's very nice of you and
uh hopefully my mom is listening i hope
she is what's her name
kathy kathy
if you're listening um well first of all
i hope you're proud of your son i think
he's doing great i think he's doing
great um
and in many areas of life but uh thank
you for birthing him
he's been a delight to know they're
pretty proud uh
the two of them both retired kathy's
retired as well yeah yeah they uh
i've been doing commercials for
lagavulin scotch
oh yes yes single malt for about seven
years now
and
they have both appeared in my
commercials oh
i think
yeah
dad more than mom because we do like
father's day
one of the we lean into father's day
with with my scotch
um but also mom and dad there's a scene
late in towards the end of parks and
recreation
where uh i've split off
uh to form my own company
called like very good building
construction
because i don't wanna i don't wanna over
toot my horn so it's called very good
construction that's funny um
and there's a meeting
around a table with like my board and my
mom and dad are
are part of the board of like that's
funny ron swanson's
family yeah and my dad they put a
mustache on my dad and i tried to get
him to put one on my mom
i think
they thought that was one bridge yeah
yeah a little too like monty python i
was gonna ask you about the uh the
scotch
with a job like that that goes on for a
length of time
did they i imagine they hired you with a
certain look with that bearded look or a
mustachioed look and do they then want
you to continue are they were they weird
were any jobs weird about you making the
decision
for megan's sake to
shave to go clean shaven
no i mean my whole life first of all the
the lagavulin job uh
is
insanely dreamy
it was ron swanson's scotch yes parks
and rec oh ron swanson pops up all the
time in memes and i mean like that is
it's funny i've been referring to you in
two different ways i mean like
that that character is so indelible in
the zeitgeist i feel like
yeah i mean through no fault of my own
it like it hit at a time like when it
kind of at the same time that social
media even hit and took over and memes
started
so uh lagavulin um
we mike
sure uh it was his favorite scotch it
coincidentally had been mine it was the
first good scotch i had ever had back
when i was 29.
and so
ron kept using it and finally uh we got
a hold of them they were you know it was
it was kind of a small company
and they hadn't they weren't really
up on it and
uh chris pratt got cast in guardians of
the galaxy
and so we were going to lose him for a
season because he was going to be
shooting in london
so this show set in a small city in
indiana
suddenly they were like the show's going
to london we're going to go shoot
a couple episodes in london oh my god
that's what they do i didn't know that
it's so smart to accommodate chris so
that we could keep him on the show
because obviously he's one of the stars
of the show
so while we were there
ron who famously hated europe was having
a terrible time he he was walking around
london taking pictures of like big ben
saying things like wow a big clock we
don't have that in america
uh
and so finally amy poehler's character
leslie knope uh
she made a scavenger hunt for ron and
he's like he loved puzzles he's like a
puzzle
and he goes up on the scavenger hunt
uh funny aside it takes him to
stonehenge and he oh actually i don't
think this made the episode we shot it
where ron goes like walking through
stonehenge and he runs into pratt
andy chris pratt's character who is so
stupid
and pratt was like is this buckingham
palace like is this completely
impossible more primitive than i would
have thought
no son i think you need to head south uh
and i'm i'm on a scavenger hunt so i'll
see you later
so so ron ends up on like a train and
then he ends up on a ferry
and then he ends up on like a little uh
fishing boat
and and we come around to bend and there
on the on the bay is the lagavulin
distillery
so leslie created a you know
a scavenger hunt to to go to his
favorite scotch distillery
so then i hit it off with the people
and we pretty much immediately just
started me making commercials for them
so we have a channel on youtube called
my tales of whiskey we've i believe we
have made 36 commercials oh my god did
you meet amy poehler in chicago i met
amy i think in 93 oh wow
uh we met because a guy in my theater
company lived in a house with matt
besser
and so we met at like a party
and we i don't know we hit it off we had
an affinity of like
hey you look like trouble hey yeah you
know you're scoundrels you're both a
little like rascals she immediately yeah
she immediately would punch me in the
arm
yeah hey hey offerman yeah yeah i can
see that yeah like a little hey you look
like a scamp she's a scam yeah
and and
the thing is
i could not have been less interested in
what the [ __ ] they were doing at second
city i was like
like i didn't even know that it was like
a pipeline to snl i backed into it in my
mid 30s megan was doing young
frankenstein on broadway
i got cast as ron swanson and she got
cast
as karen walker and will and grace both
of us at age 38. oh wow
in her case
like her whole life she's the kid in
class that you're like okay let's put on
a show obviously megan you're the lead
and then let's figure out the rest of
the show she just is so talented yeah
sure she's the most incredible singer
she's so beautiful she's like madeline
khan she's like our madeline she to me
is like that level the timing
old-fashioned entertaining um yeah she's
like an instant legend yeah she's an
institution yeah but even so the reason
she didn't have necessarily a big break
before then is because
we both had whatever our weird penchant
for like
whatever my weird sense of humor is
i'm sticking to it by the time i was 38
and i got ron swanson
by
dealing with myself honestly
as i faced the world
like my life was really happy
and and if you had told me
you you know what it's probably never
gonna work out like you can keep doing
theater
but you're just not gonna work in film
and tv
i would have been like uh great i mean i
i i'm having a pretty good time as as mr
megan mulally
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
well where did you meet i'm curious i
think you told me this but um we met
doing a play in 2000 uh in los angeles
at a company called the evidence room
that was the first spark was our sense
of humor like and you know this like
that friendship you and i and keir had
this when
we met doing this movie and i was
playing these jokes on you guys where
do you remember what was that specific i
remember you doing one with
i had to leave town and come back
and we all we all had our different like
hotel room situations
and it's some
skeezy like you know just like highway
hotel
yeah
and i went to the grocery store and got
the hugest cucumber and zucchini oh and
ginger root and then a like some
something like a big thing of vaseline
and i was just like hey you guys i gotta
i gotta leave town for like a week
can i leave some stuff in your fridge
there were clearly these crazy like
ass play toys from the grocery store
yeah they were all these huge phallic
and i know
i never
i never broke yes and you guys were like
is is this a bit like and it only weeks
later did you finally ask me about it
yes that's right that's right well
that's what that's really what endeared
us to you um
or you to us i should say because um we
loved it was another level bit i
remember it was one of the because keira
and i love doing bits but it was one
that was um
you were so committed to it and it was
also uh
it was it took place over several
like a while it was like it was patient
you're right you never broke yeah it was
a it was a [ __ ] long time and it's
like it's funny that those things make
as does as do many your your characters
are exemplary of this that they make
it's funnier
the straighter it is the longer it goes
the funnier it becomes um
there's something oh magruber is a good
example of this there's certain scenes
in macgruber where he says like
the wildest [ __ ] you know and and it's
like funny but then he just keeps
doubling down like i was like
okay you can watch me suck somebody's
dick and then why you know it goes on
totally um
yeah he's a great example of that the
great will forte yeah and um
and
so i mean so it's that sensibility it's
the reason that i
dove into that bit deeper and deeper is
because
we
i could tell it would work yeah and
that's the that's the
the uh most satisfying way to make
friends like
it's like if you it's like we're all in
church together and we figure out that i
can that you guys will giggle at me yeah
so then then i'll like
fart like
[Music]
where you guys are like oh my god i'm
gonna [ __ ] laugh the best
whatever you can ride that that
delicious
almost
it is almost sensual it is the the
pleasure so so megan and i when you when
you meet somebody backstage it is
somewhat sensual
and you develop that sense of humor of
like yeah there's some here's some [ __ ]
i'm going to say you know quietly yeah
because we're backstage
and and usually you're making jokes
about the people on youtube yes yes
can i can you see his balls through
whatever does he have three balls or is
that a really wide penis head or
whatever it is
once you find that channel
[Music]
i have these uh gourds that can i just
leave them in your refrigerator
to leave town
yeah so so that's how we like
hit off with each other so you and megan
right away was like
a similar sense of humor too and and and
whatever for the joke
our
marriage is
hard like our lives are [ __ ] hard
like the wonderful parts are super
wonderful
uh the rewards are are crazy but
the levels of stress and anxiety and
like the nimbleness it takes to like
jet around the world and be ready to
perform
in any number of ways like
and like mix our schedules
pay enough attention to each other
domestically that's the thing is to get
the time together too must be difficult
yeah well we've we have a two-week rule
that's part of our secret oh interesting
we do yeah we never take a job that will
keep us apart for more than two weeks
whatever whatever that means whether
if i shoot a show in england for two
months that means she's gonna come
visit and whatever but i mean so
but you perform together as well
sometimes we we do we do we're lucky
enough we just did some stuff together
the thing is it's arduous if whether we
were single or together
our jobs uh we're lucky enough to work a
lot as performers she also has a band
that she tours with
and so that's what what's the band
they're called nancy and beth
uh they're
they're so good
uh they're on you know streaming systems
and and if you uh go to nancy and
beth.com okay there's there's a few
videos that megan directed that are so
good she's
she's insanely talented in whatever she
puts her hand to when you are together
what what do you like to do i'm asking
also as somebody who um is curious about
having a good long relationship what
what are the things that you
make a point of doing when you are
together
we love doing jigsaw puzzles too
so like that's our thing is like
sometimes i mean sometimes sometimes we
go to a wonderful fancy hotel or you
know far flung
or we have an air steering stream we'll
take a trip in our airstream oh yeah you
have an airstream
but it's all so that we can
just be like quiet before we get bored
together yeah well [ __ ] nick i could
talk to you all day i i i'm really
taking advantage of your time i um
i just want to ask you about pam and
tommy because i'm i'm so into it that
you play porn producer or uncle milty
again that's one of those guys that i
see you play and i think it's it's it's
always funny to me to
to see the way hollywood where they
where they place you i mean the things
that you
that you do only because it's it seems
so unlike you but you're so you're so
good at it am i just describing an actor
is that just what actors do
how do you do that uh you're not a porn
producer
he had a different name yeah like
different clothes and it's crazy
same similar face
similar face um well was it fun to play
that kind of guy that really sleazy
uh you play him with charm i mean he's
quite charming
but oh gosh
thanks uh uh it was super fun i mean the
uh the scripts for pam and tommy were
wonderful and and uh the collaborators
that i love craig gillespie the director
is
just so great we just really love
working with him yeah the cast is so
incredible but and
quite honestly uh so those were those
were the initial
um
sort of carrots dangling that i that i
was like this sounds pretty good now let
me read the scripts and and then i read
the eight eight scripts
and the way that it starts out is like a
bait and switch and i and i think it's
enough of error there's no spoilers here
but
it starts out where it's like
get ready to relive the salacious story
of
motley crue rock and roll and pam
anderson playboy baywatch you know
crazy foxy whatever
sex tape you know total triple x
and
and so it has that sensibility but a the
first thing is
no one knows the real story which is the
the real story is crazy it's crazier
than what i would have imagined it's
fascinating but it's also told at least
the first the first episode is all
through the point of view it's really a
point of view of the the um
this this carpenter seth rogen plays who
has a who's a bone to pick he's treated
unfairly by tommy lee and feels like he
he needs to um exact some sort of karmic
revenge and but it's it's so well done
uh so
written i
it's it's i i can't recommend it enough
to people but um it must have been a
surprise to to have read that turn to it
was for me to watch it that was the
final hook is that then it's
it's kind of from seth's point of view
but then by the time you get sort of
halfway through it comes around
to pam's point of view
and this very specific way in which she
is a victim
because uh because she's a woman like
it's it's really pointed up that that
tommy lee
doesn't really suffer from it because
he's a [ __ ] dude
high five bro
but she
has some great things to say about how
how
you're treated if you go into the [ __ ]
business as it were
like like like as soon as you if you're
a woman who takes her top off you
basically you give up right yeah you
give up autonomy yeah it's really
disgusting
so that for me was the biggest incentive
was like oh this this is a great uh a
very cleverly uh
structured
piece of like feminist property totally
yeah uh oh got too much there's too much
but this is but i have to do this really
quick liking around nick um what is you
i can't believe this is gonna be a tough
one what is your favorite emoji nick
offerman
favorite emoji uh
the uh the lady doing a cartwheel oh
yeah
yeah
that's my that that one most closely
resembles me inside
oh really do you okay
um who was your first celebrity crush
uh grizzly adams was it was a tv show
okay i thought grizzly
and his his best friend was a bear named
ben
what is your favorite
ice cream flavor
i mean th there's uh there's this
talentee gelato
is so good that
that's popular and they're they're
salted oh i think i've had it flavor oh
god damn uh i want to mention jenny's
ice cream i don't know if you've tried
jenny's before i i love jenny's yeah
what is your favorite holiday
i i'm gonna say thanksgiving even though
it's a [ __ ] holiday like all the
trappings are [ __ ] and so so i don't
the thing i love about it is it's the
it's the occasion
that's about getting our family together
and give it giving thanks
for for the bounty uh of our year
that that's not [ __ ] and
and it's delicious food and it's a
repast
of stuffing and love well what is what
is an acclaimed movie that you're
embarrassed to admit you've never seen
that that maybe people shame you for um
pritzy's honor some that have come up
recently with megan sunset boulevard
there's there's just a million i know
yeah princess honor i know there's for
me it was dirty dancing uh for a while a
pretty woman people
go berserk on me women especially not to
i don't think i ever saw a pretty woman
i saw a dirty i wonder what megan would
say i'm 27 times will you do me a huge
favor because at the end of these
episodes only if you remember nick uh
we like to include a little voice note i
take i record a lot of like people if
there's a way to record you telling
megan
that you've never seen
pretty woman
because i'm curious what her reaction
would be because i at my experience has
been the women in my life um are
outraged by it i think she's pretty
calloused to that to
the depths of my ignorance by now okay
where i i could be like
i've never heard of uh the bible and it
should be like oh god of course yeah
classic because you were in your wood
shop
does she
does she come to the wood shop she has i
mean
she's very much not a
wood shop person
which i mean you know
in many ways we are very uh green acres
you know yeah you are it's true um yeah
but uh but yeah it's you know it's i i
i there's no shame in it i mean the
that's part of how i became good at
building furniture was by not seeing a
lot of movies like yeah that's true
that's true no i know there shouldn't be
shame i know i'm not um but sometimes
people get uh
yeah what is a game show pastor present
that you'd want to be a contestant on
i
want to be a contestant on i guess i'm
going to go with family feud uh oh yeah
richard dawson edition uh do you drink
coffee or tea and if so how do you take
it wow uh i love both and i and i
toggle between them i love a powerful
like a robust
coffee shop coffee and i take take it
black
and i love black tea specifically
there's a great company out of portland
called smith tea company
they make a tea with
megan's band called nancy and beth
or i don't know if i don't know if they
still do but they made like a a special
thing
and so they sent some
samples and i
one of the samples was portland
breakfast
and i love english breakfast and irish
breakfast scottish breakfast this
portland breakfast holy [ __ ]
okay i'm gonna check it out it's the
greatest
okay smith tea company i also drink that
black i just i love really okay a reborn
beverage
a what a rebort a reborative beverage
reborative is a word that i found in the
the maritime novels of patrick o'brien
he uses it uh in reference imagine being
on a wet wintry ship in in
uh victoria's england you know yeah and
and the steward kilik will always
prepare a pot of coffee which
would be so incredibly warming in that
instance and they always say that it's a
most reborative beverage wow and i love
you i love that word i love the context
and then i was heartbroken to discover
it's not in the
dictionary really so i'm i'm using it
lobbying i'm gonna bring it back
this is uh the grassroots campaign to
bring it um or to to bring it to the
dictionary for the first time reportive
okay i hope someone from webster's is
listening if you could learn another
language what would it be espanol no
question like i'm embarrassed that i
don't speak it
me too i've been trying dueling since
the pandemic i've been trying duolingo
and
i have to up my game it's just been slow
going excellent
um oh oh you see you got it
what is your favorite cereal
favorite cereal god uh it's changed over
the years but but yeah but my answer now
and i don't even know if it counts is
like
yogurt granola and blueberries
if you had to choose a different first
name besides nick what would it be
uh buck
that's perfect
what what is your favorite uh oh if you
had a sandwich um if there was the nick
offerman sandwich what would be on it
what would it be comprised of corned
beef
melted
swiss
stone ground mustard
yum
uh on toasted rye which is so pretty
pretty close to a reuben but no crowd it
is
but but it's it sounds delicious um what
is your favorite tom hanks movie or a
cubano
uh i love it a cubano sandwich uh is
maybe even better
favorite tom hanks movie
sheesh um but would you add anything to
the cubano or take something away to
make it a nick offer no i mean i know
you can add salami and that's called
tampa style and uh i'll take it either
way that's a goddamn delicious sandwich
okay oh um
i'm gonna go i'm going to go big yeah
yeah it's
nothing i mean it's hard to it makes
sense it's hard to beat big tom hanks i
know it is hard to pick i know and then
you start remembering when you really
start going through the role i'm going
to i'm going to buck the system and go
cloud
atlas oh man
yeah
we might have to retire that question
uh
would you rather take a time machine to
the past or the future
time machine to the past or the future
i'd i wouldn't go
okay not interested
okay
you'll be safe now okay are you a more
of a talker or a texter
i prefer talking
but the numbers would say texting
yeah are you a night or a morning person
nick morning
uh beecher mountains
mountains
do you have a preference the toilet roll
over or under absolutely uh over unless
you have a cat
oh yeah you know what's funny there's
like one around here they play with it
yes interesting i would never have known
that and if you would nick finally um
finish the sentence for us life is short
so
order that second cheeseburger
yeah that's great um
well buddy i really i don't want this to
end well i'm you know especially in the
pandemic but uh it's wonderful to see
you yeah in general i'm crazy about you
me too but also
at the in the last couple of years
getting to just socialize
even in this weird zoom
capacity buddy i
this has been such i mean selfish
component of this for me is to like i
know just catch up let's go make dinner
and come back and have dinner together
and then go to sleep like staring at
each other
we'd love it i would love it a nice
hearty um sustainable
meal that's right i would love it um i
got a few more pillowcases full of kale
too okay okay that'll keep you moving
well i have an appetite uh thank you
thank you for having me and thanks for
keeping your health uh likewise nick
thanks and and give megan my best and um
yeah i'll i'll let you know where i'm at
and try to find you in the world
we'll do we'll see you soon all right
thanks pal bye
[Music]
so
that just happened
yeah yeah it was um
yeah you know there's a
it's it's this area i think
that just happened you say that every
time he's also so funny i mean he's so
funny beyond dry like dry is he dries a
bone he's a good driest person
as a mutton bone such a funny story that
he told um trying to make his friends
laugh and church and it's so easy to
picture him doing the gospel reading
totally it his past like him talking
about his past it all
fits perfectly fine
you know it all like everything fits
into place yes yes i know that story his
his genesis story is um like where where
that speaking of the bible yes oh my god
i know now i'm thinking of genesis
you know that those passages being read
um that gospel being read
by because we hear we would hear it
every it was easter yeah and uh in in
the beginning you know and i can hear
him now reading that on the second day
yes god created the last mosquitoes
but he has a grab it i mean it's it's
hard to compare him to anyone he really
does feel like a unique one-of-a-kind
person
and he also
is such a renaissance man like a true
renaissance man i want him to be my
guide
yes you know i i want to know where he
gets his meat i want i want to get that
tea that he likes you know i i like you
know both want to know like where nick
government gets all the things he
ingests because he knows so much [ __ ] i
know and he his knowledge base seems so
vast and well-rounded like like really a
renaissance person yes
but also what i appreciate him
maybe the most is that despite all the
stuff he knows like clearly he is such a
knowledgeable curious like well-read
person
he is also very open about
what he doesn't know and his fallibility
and how he has so much more to learn i
know and it's not like that [ __ ] no
i know like faux
faux modesty you know it's like he
really does believe that he has a lot to
learn and and he's excited to learn it
yeah he's a real
you need to have that you yeah to be a
true renaissance person that's true you
need to
really truly acknowledge how much
room you need yeah you have to learn
yeah i had never met anyone like him and
and it's funny that you say that because
i look i've googled i looked up because
i want to order this what is it smith
it's smithtea.com
and portland breakfast i'd like to get
more into tea me too because you know
both of you want to get into tea because
i think i drink too much coffee yes
and i know like a little caffeine is not
the worst thing in the world but it's
it's not it's also not the best well
does this sound good to you this is uh
them describing the portland breakfast
tea big strong so far that's nick
separated snag big strong and assertive
with notes of malt leather spice and a
touch of peat did he create this
sounds right up his alley not quite as
astringent as other breakfast teas just
rich dark and perfect for a rainy
portland morning um that sounds so good
and also it's funny that you said the
thing about the meats because i'm you
know i'm trying to eat less meat and i
want to be conscious conscientious of
where i get the meat from certainly and
so i texted him the other day because i
was
i've been getting really getting into uh
bone broths and and their medicinal
qualities and and um so i've been making
a lot of uh
soups and stuff and i said hey do you
have any good meat sources in la i know
i asked you this but it slipped my mind
doing a lot of cooking this month and he
said he sent me back these two
one was the infatuation.com 13 excellent
la butcher shops and then the other was
one was mccall's meat and fish company
if people are interested in the calls
meat and fish company well you know what
else is good the uh happy valley happy
valley's good on the east that's east
coast uh belcampo i know in l.a but they
had a i looked them up and there was a
little uh
scandal
but um anyway yeah some good options i
know but i wanted anybody who any who i
just wanna like pick his brain well you
don't both want to want nickel for me to
be your guide in life i know me too he
seems like such a um an authority on
things that i really care about
gardening i want to like you know figure
out where he gets his top sword building
i know
i've been to his shop and it's really i
was there a while ago sounds like it's
really expanded but um i i couldn't
believe he did that he was doing it by
himself then he went he was making um
he was i remember him making a canoe
uh he was like he's like that's my
that's my baby i'm working on that for
myself and like but then he was making
furniture for people and it's so cool i
really admire that in 10 years from now
if i ended up a little bit like nick
offman i think my life would be in
pretty good shape if you were an offer
boy
we were both ultra boys yes yes
he's the best yeah let's read a letter
okay great wow yeah
good episode we want to make it yeah
nice and tight okay
this is from a letter from
oh we were talking about this name the
other day
uh sean it's sean k spelled the way that
used to confuse me w
no no that that was the one that i i've
seen
there was a sean roof in my in my class
and that was always the one that like i
understood s-h-a-w-n but seeing i for
when i was a kid for a while i thought
it was cn you weren't the brightest kid
no
but now i'm seeing that it's shawn
okay uh hi justin and christian i
started listening to your podcast during
the lockdown and i've kept listening
because you guys come off as so
genuinely yourselves thank you sean um
normally when i say that to someone
there's a great deal of sarcasm involved
that's not the case here mostly
that's funny
wait a minute that's not the case here
it's not he's not being sarcastic he's
being a little little how can you be a
little sarcastic about that you guys
come off as so gen genuinely yourselves
maybe from time to time we don't yeah
okay wow you're a real sean apologist
so that's what i dwell on i know you go
to the negative yeah
back to sean
uh i've been a ravenous consumer of
movies and shows both before and after
the streaming revolution
my favorites i've never heard that
streaming revolution it's true it was a
revolution it was my favorites of course
being accepted dodgeball idiocracy live
free or die hard the breakup and most of
all
lady of the manor okay hey i hope that's
not the that's the
party's i'm [ __ ] with you wink yeah
yeah no he hasn't done that yet
back to sean i have had friends who
could carry entire conversations using
only movie show quotes
which brings me he didn't say movie show
he said movie slash show quotes which
brings me to ask you both what are your
go-to lines in conversation
your go-to lines in conversation uh the
ones i've used the most lately are
uh will have so much room for activities
yes yeah we i use that i use that yeah
i've used that quite a bit actually
that's a great that line when he starts
kicking around he starts like
a lot actually me too i forgot to ask
you do you like guacamole that's the
good one oh there's so many from step
right it's not just good lines it's like
useful lines that you inject in
conversations yeah i think that's reason
yes yeah what are your go to yeah and
then all right i'll write all right from
of course
i use
is that occasionally um that's a good
question oh he has another one you keep
using that word i do not think it means
what you think it means
you know that uh prince yeah i didn't do
the right accent
you keep using that word i don't think
you
princess bride yes c also inconceivable
yeah um
that's a good question go two lines it's
hard to know until i've gone to them i
do um yeah i think i quote
i think cool what about bob a lot yeah
waiting for guffman yeah thumbs up a lot
like um it came up the other day um
oh we were talking about it earlier
today yeah yeah it was earlier today we
were telling you it was a it's a song
that gets stuck in your head yeah almost
annoying
yeah yeah um or when it's drive and get
a coke which i don't know if you're
thirsty or if you're watching someone
perform or something somebody who's like
like american idol or something you go
they're good yeah well they can really
sing strike it it's right yeah it's
still oh man i go to what about bob i go
to goffman a lot i'm i do back to the
future a lot a lot are you telling me i
mean there's that comes up a lot um
you're my ma you're my um
purple on cow yeah i go
those are the ones that are at like the
forefront i would say what about bob um
uh i knew i knew you're playing streams
and automobiles i mean they're like kind
of more random um
i'm sure i thought so many but but you
know what i do on film i was doing this
on the last job i did i'll i'll have
like i'll just start saying
line you know i'll i love bonding with
the crew about you know go to line like
big lebowski lines or yeah
or like will ferrell and zoolander i
feel like i'm taking crazy yeah
there was one the other day i was
describing somebody and and that ben
stiller's cough and zoolander i was
doing
when like somebody's like faking an
illness and like yeah it's
i would say but i would say
uh the step brothers line i might use
that more than anything else
comes up a lot yeah and a lot of people
said did we just become best friends and
that not as much for me but it's the
activities yeah there's so much room for
activities yeah that does come up a lot
yeah me too
um okay back to now i'm thinking of all
the women there's so many
uh movies are great um
back to sean uh i'm in under on the
toilet paper roll by the way i learned
this when i lived with cats
yes that is a common denominator you
just mentioned that yeah we did yeah you
just did with nick oh really yeah yeah
you said the cat just funny yeah the cat
claws them down and plays with them it's
so funny
when cats do that um
anyway sean back to sean would you
rather be able to have yes would you
rather be able to have sex only once a
year and have a glorious orgasm
or be able to have as much sex as
humanly possible but have only one
yearly orgasm that you could not
predict i have sex only once a year
and i would predict but would it be
glorious
i mean i would say all orgasms are
somewhat glorious i would say that not
all orgasms are created the same
no no i i agree which i've yes i agree
uh but you don't have to agree i do i i
definitely do definitely not all the
same no
um
but i can find that well i will also say
the worst ones
are great very exactly yeah my worst
yeah has still been like something i
would it's never been disappointing no
i'm never like
that's not true it's been disappointing
you think of course in the in your whole
life disappointing relatively bad not
like exactly
exactly but doesn't oh oh you're right
disappointing disappointing relative to
what you know it could be exactly yeah
that's true um but you're right never
bad i've never had a bad
um like oh man that uh
what was it like
ow
it's never been that
we're like oh no
um okay um
okay so i i would lean towards as
much as you can and have only one yearly
or yeah but i don't know but like as
much as humanly possible does that mean
you like
you have to have sex like four no no
he says because that would that would be
tough oh no that he said
he said be able to have as much sex is
humanly better okay so like you can have
whatever you want yeah um then as long
as you're partnering with course
i mean i think you would have to pick
that
just for the sake of intimacy yeah i
wouldn't
you would kill your relationship if you
yeah you can only do that also it's fine
i mean even without orgasm even if you
don't have an orgasm yeah oh that's so
funny that's easy um unless the only
difference is if the question was
i have as much sex as possible
but your orgasms hurt or something oh
that's a good question like then it's
something to think of they hurt
that's a good question so if they hurt
if it is
orgasm feels like stubbing your toe no
it's like stubbing your penis
then i might have to
find different ways to to be intimate oh
my god
what was that thing we were watching
where the guy was pulling on his force
he was trying to people oh yeah
this is a great recommendation uh oh how
to yes with john wilson yes on hbo oh
man is it good brilliant i think the
second season's better because he has
more access you know he has an amazing
thrill he's like a team he has writers
that are like really yeah really like
great that show is incredible
uh how to but that reminded me a little
bit of like is stubbing you to stop your
penis it'd be like
that it's just an uncomfortable
momentary like not a
tremendous amount of pain but enough but
enough so that you wouldn't be excited
to uh start the process in the first
place you know but it was here's what
you would have to do just like hold off
on the orgasm you would have to just
have sex up until that would be
frustrating comfortable in a very
different way though yeah
yeah and and you know the the option
this once a year with the glorious
orgasm option would be so talk about
disappointing afterwards disappointing
is that real that kevin sorbo thing i
don't know um
if you're curious what we're talking
about if this ever get if this gets left
in google kevin sorbo and disappointing
those words the legend is that he said
it he just read the
the stage direction
um and
he was just meant to say this word in a
disappointing way
but uh he just
yelled out disappointed
anyway uh played hercules yes um but the
glorious uh the glorious orgasm option
it would be so disappointing to like
when it was over
you know because it's just this moment
it's a momentary thing and then when
it's over you think oh i won't be able
to like touch this person for another
year i have sex with this person for
another year
yeah or at all i know i know it's i
would definitely
sex a lot with the one but the painful
orgasm
that's a different question
i guess i would still do the painful
orgasm one and just
well cassette says you're right it's
like i would integrate i would i think i
would pick the not have sex and just
find other ways to be intimate you know
find like new agey ways of being
interested oh yeah like steve like
candles yeah drink teas and like
more like uh yeah like east journey kind
of
yeah like practices crafty sure or
whatever that i mean i don't know i
actually don't really know what i'm
picturing right now but i think there's
other ways to connect other than
sexual intercourse intercourse sex so
but you could argue that like that
tantric stuff that you're you're like i
guess referring to
is a form of sex that but but it's
intimacy it's i don't know if that fits
in sean's definition of sex yeah i guess
we'd have to know what sex is because
yeah uh please have to please up the
good work please i missed a word please
just please up the good work what was
the word you missed please keep up the
good duh but um maybe that was my
subconscious maybe the freudian slip
please up the good work well up you're
thinking of keep it up maybe yeah you're
better so so that you never have to be
starting to keep certain body parts up
oh yeah oh maybe that's what i was
thinking
who knows please keep up the good work
it helps all of us to be a little less
worse
that's nice
a little less worse i'll take that yeah
sean in las vegas
man oh man you know speaking of vegas uh
who i'd really like to get on the show
is carrot top
yeah you know he um i listened to an
interview of his the other day and he's
really like introspective and
interesting and has had such uh
he's been such an interesting career
such a he was talking about like
yeah fame and and his relationship to it
and
um
and working out you know he kind of
acknowledged that he got you know the
things you think when you think of
carrot top i think now of like
weirdly muscular steroids steroids and
stuff and but he addresses he's no
longer doing that he's like kind of like
bad plastic surgery yeah and he kind of
he was very um
forthcoming about and like honest in
any
who thanks sean uh and if you guys would
like to write in our email address is
life is short at wondering.com and
thanks to oh the hopefully my future
guide in life yes your your muse yes um
and the megan mullally's a delicious
side dish cuddly yeah cuddly bear of a
husband nick offerman man we love you we
really do he's [ __ ] great and um
thank you to him for all of his wisdom
the pearls that he dropped on this
year's show
and thanks to all of you for listening
and uh we will talk to you
next week i can't wait
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's uh co-hosted and produced
by you christian long's also produced by
megan the monaco and katie the alan and
there's a uh there's an audio engineer
on this one sergio enriquez but before
that yes i know there's a senior
producer michelle
and who could forget our executive
producer marshall louie all of it is for
wondering
[Music]
crap yeah think of a song you like
okay
now start singing it in all meows
[Music]
yum yum
good job
you